>> CHAO: Hello, my name is Gerald Chao. I'm
the founder and CTO of Lingospot. This is
our Homepage. So, let me tell you a little
about Lingospot and how we use Google App
Engine to help us deliver our services across
the Web. So, here is an example, a publisher
of ours. This is the Sacramento B. This is
a newspaper in the Sacramento, California
area. What we do is we will give for any given
article, we’ll analyze this text. For example,
this is a CDC article about Swine Flu, and
we’ll determine what the interesting topics
within this are. What page? So, for example,
we identify that Swine Flu and CDC is an interesting
topic and we’ll turn them automatically
into links. So additionally, we also created
this related articles we get so, a reader
of this article can find out more about related
Swine Flu articles from Sac B. So, let’s
say, if I’m a reader and I’m interested
to find out more about Swine Flu, I can click
on that link and I will be taken to a page
about, we call this topic page all about Swine
Flu. So, related articles, images, Twitter,
Wikipedia, trend charts, videos, etc. So,
the way we’re using App Engine is to allow
us to surf traffic across the Web for any
given publisher that we signed up. So, we
are working with Sac B Forbes dot com, and
a large advocate news aggregator called paper.com.
So, we also have publishers all around the
world, in Japan, in Singapore, India and some
in the U.K. So, App Engine allows us to be
able to deliver our services like these widgets
and these links, as well as the topic portals,
or all around the world instantaneously. And
we don't have to worry about sealing out our
services. So, we also have a console that
a publisher can be able to configure their
topic portals so they can move things around
and be able to determine what goes into each
one of these content boxes and we can then
targeted the content of a given article to
that particular related article. So, this
means that we have a lot of dynamic content
we have to deliver. So, Google App Engine
allows us to very easily deliver a lot of
different dynamic content across the globe
very efficiently. So, we’ve been very happy
with Google App Engine. We pretty much started
looking at it when it first came out about
10 months ago and at that time we’re comparing
them with Amazon. And Amazon just didn't do
it for us because we have custom logics and
we need to develop as far as the cash expiration
policy and how we wanted to deliver the quality
of service. So, when App Engine came along
and we’re a Python shop, so the, all of
our console and services were in Jangle. So
Power App Engine and Python was a perfect
fit for us. So, we started using initially
the memo cash API, the EOL Fetch API within,
we added data source API, so, it has worked
out really well for us. And then we are trying
to migrate more and more of our Jangle logic
into App Engine because then we don't have
to worry about scaling out the application
letter which is our Jangle and we’re just
focusing on delivering it and then some of
our back end which is the analysis engine
which we host ourselves. So, there is hybrid
approach right now, works really well for
us and then we’ll migrate as many pieces
as we can away from our data center into App
Engine. All right so, I’m here at Google
I/O 2009 and I just heard about all the great
things that Google App Engine is introducing
today or tomorrow. One of it is essentially
a background task where you can add task to
your Q and it will be processed in the background.
So, that's one of the limitations that we
have before, is that some requests especially
that’s maybe CPU or I/O intensive, we cannot
guarantee within the number of seconds that
we have to return. So, these background Qs
are perfect for us to process these things
in the background. So that’s to introduce
here at Google I/O and then also large file
delivery, and so, in case we have large images
or video files even, we can just have store—upload
it to Google App Engine and they’ll have
it delivered around the world. So, these are
just examples where App Engine is adding new
features as we also have been moving and migrating
more and more of our pieces into App Engine
and we really look forward to growing with
App Engine as we grow our service in the future.